[Music]
our briefs today for this panel is to
explore the ways in which artificial
intelligence can work for us
augmented intelligence is the phrase and
it's it's it's the benevolent face of
artificial intelligence but let's step
back for a moment for a little bit of
history john JCR Licklider was a Harvard
trained psychologist an MIT teacher and
he was the first head of the technology
office at the Advanced Research Projects
Agency he funded some of the basic
research behind the personal computer
and what became the Internet and in 1960
he wrote a classic sa man computer
symbiosis and in it he said that the
appropriate role for computing was to
augment same word human knowledge and
intelligence rather than supplanted and
so for decades we've been debating this
issue back and forth always in a new
context and it and it's that the theme
seems familiar the context today seems
drastically different and that's what
our panel is going to explore today our
first guest is an IBM fellow and manager
multimedia division at IBM Watson
Research Center he reads IBM's research
and development on visual comprehension
including its use in IBM Watson please
welcome John R Smith
next is the Arthur's a trend professor
bioethics and the director of the Center
for Bioethics at New York University he
is also the author of current
controversies in bioethics and is the
editor-in-chief for the journal of moral
philosophy please welcome Matthew Liao
our next panelist is vice-president for
products and strategy for integrate AI a
toronto-based start-up her company uses
artificial intelligence to help
businesses improve and transform
customer experiences to make those
experiences more natural more human-like
please welcome Catherine Huber also
joining us is a professor at the NYU
Stern School of Business and it's Center
for data science he is the editor in
chief for the journal big data and he is
also the founder of SCT Capital
Management whose machine learning
software is used to make automated
trading decisions in the financial
markets please welcome Vasant dark
so John let's start with you give us
your take on artificial intelligence and
you what you know what is different now
and where is it where are we where is it
heading and give us a few examples from
the work that IBM is doing currently
since you guys have been doing this for
you know oh you know decades if however
it's been defined over the years sure so
I'm a research scientist at the at IBM
and and by training you know I I'm an
expert in computer vision and and at IBM
what this has meant is I'm teaching
Watson to see but let me take a step
back a little bit from from that there
was a seminal moment more recently an AI
and in 2011 where IBM built a computer
system in a lot of ways right at the
cusp of this second push in AI that was
able to participate on Jeopardy not only
was it able to compete against humans it
was able to defeat the world champions
at jeopardy so this really opened the
minds of a lot of researchers and of
course a lot of work has continued since
then and I think we're finding ourselves
in a period of AI where you know again
it seems like amazing things are
possible since then since 2011 of course
you know with jeopardy all of the
questions were basically dealing with
language so there were no images on
Jeopardy however since then the the the
challenges around computer vision where
I do work around language translation
around speech recognition you know many
perceptual tasks ai has been able to
make really great great advances and I
think it's put us in a position now
where we can think of many different
industries and how we can take these
capabilities which you know are now
doing amazing things and combine them
together with human expert
to make a really significant impact
Catherine you've written a bit about
this but what do you thinks the biggest
misperception about artificial
intelligence god I think there's all
sorts of misperceptions that are out
there
it makes headlines to talk about the end
of work and in a nun's panel we're
talking about augmented intelligence
versus the machines suddenly replacing
us all and we can all just sit around
for the rest of our lives and play video
games and smoke pot and try to figure
out what to do with ourselves so so I
think that's a misperception I think I
my percept my perspective here is coming
from doing a lot of work with large
enterprises who are in the process of
trying to adopt and make real
applications from a lot of the
theoretical research coming out of
academic research units and things like
computer vision so using computers and
showing them pictures of a puppy or
pictures of a glass of wine and without
any associated metadata they can they
can recognize that and they can
accurately label those tasks so so I in
doing this work with enterprises I've
seen that it's just a lot harder than
one would think it's not like you can as
in the matrix right if anybody's seen
the matrix where Keanu Reeves puts a
little chip in his brain and the next
thing you know he can he's an expert
karate master right so we have this this
impression when we think about augmented
intelligence that the systems will get
so smart that we can put our little
chips in and then we will be fluent in
German after one day of work as opposed
to passing the Malcolm Gladwell Ian
10,000 hours in order to win so it
learns some new skill but in practice it
does take time and it often takes a
articulated artfully articulated
collaboration between men and machine in
order to get going with systems so when
I'm working with large Wall Street banks
or insurance companies or media
companies often I'll meet with sort of
an executive layer and the impression
that they have is that they can go from
absolutely manual processes to complete
Netflix like automation in three or four
months and they asked us to scope out
projects like this where they can just
plug in a machine and you know we're
sort of ready to go and what I like
about stitched Fitch Stix stitch fix is
and I'll use this as a metaphor to help
them understand what this might really
look like do anybody know where it is
yeah I'll explain it so it
so this is a it's an e-commerce shopping
personal shopping site so you go in and
you know say you're a woman and you're
sick and tired of shopping so you can
sign up for an account and they ask you
to fill out a form that tells you some
data about yourself so you know your
height your weight your size some take
your taste in clothing so you can go on
Pinterest and and pick out examples of
images of clothing that you might like
and you send this off into the ether and
the next thing you know a month later
they you get a little box that has five
items of clothing that that stitch fix
assumes and predicts might be might be
something that you'd like so this is
partially algorithmic right so the first
pass that stitch fix does is to put this
into some big algorithmic recommender
system where it parses the features that
you've input and then outputs
recommended items but then they pass it
to a set of personal stylists who are
just 1099 workers who go through and
they curate a selection that that will
likely be of interest to the final and
end consumer of the service so basically
they've artfully combined human
intelligence to give feedback to those
algorithms and then all of the data
oriented algorithmic work and I like
this as a metaphor or I mean literal
business model as well as metaphor for
enterprises that are trying to get
started with these tools because if we
take an example of say automating a
sales process in a large bank there's a
lot of of know-how and knowledge and
subject matter expertise trapped within
the heads of the current employees and
the task here is to tease out some of
those insights and and transform them
into statistical patterns and systems so
that there can be this give-and-take and
always with a feedback loop to
eventually five years down the line
maybe get to the point where the scales
tip to the the system is doing more of
the work than the people but certainly
not over overnight so so the big
misperception here I think is the sort
of inflated hyperbole around the fact
that the machines are getting so smart
they're gonna they're gonna take over
jobs tomorrow why don't you pick up on
that since you're the dummy
you know quite hedge-fund if you were
sure so the way I sort of look at the
financial landscape is in terms of sort
of high-frequency trading where the
machine's out at the end of the day just
very short-term decisions on one extreme
and on the other hand you have a long
term decision making a la Warren Buffett
style where you're looking at factors
that you know the machine really has no
basis for picking up on and that's a
very human to manage endeavor yes and
it's just just much more qualitative and
there's not enough data right so it
really boils down to does the Machine
have enough data and then the middle you
have sort of short-term trading where
you might hold for days a weeks so in
the on the left hand side in the high
frequency side there's lots of examples
lots of repeated instances and you can
learn the machine has a basis for
learning and that game was over a long
time ago machines took that over from
humans on the right hand side you have
machines that really don't have a basis
for making a decision so that's an
inherently human endeavor not that
humans do particularly well at it
in fact most humans actually
underperform the market you know warren
buffett and a few others being notable
exceptions and in the middle you have
sort of this intermediate space where
you have enough data and the machine has
a basis to learn and trade on its own my
experience is that humans really aren't
capable of making too many decisions in
a day right if you actually have enough
data then models of man tend to be
better than man that that's what the
research generally tends to show you
know human emotions kind of get in the
way and so you know when we talk about
augmented intelligence you have to ask
yourself who's augmenting who you know
is the Machine augmenting humans which
has been sort of the traditional
decision support model for 50 years and
that makes a lot of sense because there
are problems where you don't have enough
data for the machine to actually make
you to be making your decision and so
that makes a lot of sense on the other
hand if
it's machine augmenting if it's man
augmenting machine then it then I feel
that it's sort of a matter of time
before the machine does better because
you're training it to do better and then
you should expect it to do better over
time so sort of to put this all together
the way I sort of look at the world is
you know if you imagine sort of
predictability on this x-axis and cost
per error on the y-axis then problems
that fall on the lower right are very
amenable to automated decision-making
you know you have high predictability
and low cost per error and problems to
the left are difficult to automate
because there's low predictability
relative to the gospel error now
interestingly driverless cars are highly
predictable right so you might expect
those to be automated but at the moment
the cost of mistakes is very high so
they're also very high on the y-axis
which is why we're reluctant to cede
control of our transportation yet to the
Machine because we're just not sure of
the sort of edge cases or when stuff
goes wrong it could go badly wrong so I
suspect that that will happen very
gradually and isn't there another kind
of aspect here where there are
categories of decisions I mean so much
of this technology which you know we
used to call data science which is you
know data plus machine learning
algorithms we now all call AI right it
was it's it's principal use was
increasing your odds of making a sale
you know predictive product predictions
you know targeted advertising that sort
of thing and and that's fine for
decisions we're better on average is
great I mean one of my favorite data
science is woman named Claudia pearl I
get her line on this she works
used to work for Watson claims and and
now works for an ad targeting firm and
her line is it look this is a great time
for experimentation in marketing because
what happens if my algorithm it's you
know it's somebody sees the wrong ad
it's not a false positive for breast
cancer but we're moving into these
categories of things we're better on you
you're affecting individuals lives you
know medical diagnosis hiring decisions
and landing decisions where you know
individual these are high stakes
decisions
individual lives and that seems to me
it's a different kind of category isn't
well so medical diagnosis for your
transpose yes so it that falls sort of
somewhere in the middle so let's say
diabetes prediction and diagnosis fall
some in the middle of the spectrum and
machines do reasonably well but they
still make lots of errors right so they
still made this still significant
numbers of false positives and false
negatives which can be particularly
injurious if you sort of miss something
and so for that reason the way machines
are really used is sort of to make that
first cart and categorize people into
various levels of risk that humans can
then you know pursue in a more
structured kind of fashion but it sort
of comes down to that the cost for
errors there are still pretty high so
you're not going to cede control of that
to the machine on the other hand imagine
that we now have genomic data available
right the trouble with healthcare is
that most healthy people have very few
points of contact with the healthcare
system so there isn't enough data about
them right now where is the sick people
there's lots of data about them but it's
usually too late to do much about it so
you can imagine that in the future as
you get more data about people your
physician could very well be a machine
as well or at least the machine could
play a much larger role in advising you
on your health Catherine mentioned
you're not putting chips and brains
actually this is some area of research
that Matthews done a lot on and it talks
about you know brain machine interfaces
some of primitive ones we have now any
explorers kind of the future of this and
in terms of what you call the control
problem so elaborate on it so I'm a
philosopher and a bioethicists so in the
bioethics community there's talk of
human cognitive enhancement so one way
to amplify our intelligence so it is to
sort of amplify biological intelligence
to get us to become smarter biologically
speaking but there's another way which
is to do some sort of symbiosis where we
begin to use computer parts right and
our smartphone is kind of like that you
might think that your smartphone is kind
of like an extended mind an extension of
your mind
but there's more now there's something
called brain machine interfaces where
there's something called transcranial
stimulation so you sort of put something
over your head so companies are
marketing this to athletes so that they
can sort of perform better they can
learn better learn quicker and there's
actually evidence that it's not quite
like the matrix style of you know being
able to learn a language right away but
it turns out that you can learn things
up faster you remember things more using
even transcranial stimulation which is
actually a very crude technology and
there's something else called a deep
brain simulation which is much more
invasive and so where basically you're
inserting a thin electrode into your
brain and then it's connected to a
battery pack and then you sort of you
can adjust the the mode the electrical
currents and it's a sensor electrical
current to your brain and about a
hundred thousand people in the world
today have already a deep brains at DBS
and they use it for things like
Parkinson's disease epilepsy etc up
short even depression and so but the the
interesting about thing about DBS right
now is that it's it's an open-loop
system and what that means is it's user
controlled right so you kind of
manipulate you sort of you adjust the
level of the electricity but DARPA the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency for example it's quite interested
in something called a closed-loop system
where the the implant itself will auto
monitor your mood your brain state and
your emotional state so say you're a
soldier in the war and all of a sudden
you started to panic you know send what
DARPA wants to do is sort of send some
sort of automatic electrical signal to
calm you down for example right and so
we automatically monitor your emotions
and then adjust them on your on your
behalf and that raises all sorts of
questions about whether this is gonna
solve the control problem because well
you know if the machines deciding that
for you then who's really in control
right who's really augmenting who what
Masson talking about what worries you
about you know at what level because
we're talk about cyborgs basically right
the deeper philosophical
one issue that's gonna come up is so say
so it's it's going beyond augmentation
towards integration right and when you
have this type of integration one issue
is that it's gonna be is this gonna
still be me right
so in this literature it gets a bit
science-fictiony some people talk about
uploading your mental content taking
like copying all your mental content and
uploading it to the cloud you know so
you think kind of like her you know if
you've seen the movie her and then sort
of and that's so one issue the thing
about that is that when you upload the
mental content into the cloud it's not
gonna be you and here's a way to think
about why it's not going to be you so
imagine that you take you make a
thousand copies of that right and just
run it in thousand different locations
now you're supposed to be only in one
location right and so and and so it
seems like if it's running a thousand
copies all that all those copies cannot
be you right but the integration part
seems like maybe you can kind of
preserve some sort of identity if it's
more much more integrated if some sort
of if our our carbon-based cells can
interact with isomorphic
non-carbon-based cells sort of talk to
each other if we can kind of get at that
level so a lot of people are working on
this particular problem right sort of
getting cells by a biological cells to
talk to digital cells you know and if
that can happen then we can begin to
acquire some sort of integration and it
can still be you John let's bring this
back a little back what what is IBM
working on healthcare or something
that's an example of sort of augmented
intelligence that that you might that is
either in the marketplace or in the labs
demonstrated right that can be done now
that you wouldn't have thought could
have been done five years ago so you
know there are many really good examples
I'll talk about one you know one is in
in in healthcare so you know today if we
think about a problem like skin cancer
actually millions of people around the
world every year
affected by skin cancer and if we look
at melanoma in particular it's actually
a very deadly form of skin cancer where
in the u.s. 10,000 people die each year
the computer can work together with the
clinician sort of addressing the fact
that people don't always make good
decisions they have their own biases
they get tired their subjectivity you
know there's a you know there's a lot
there the computer is objective and the
computer you know that's you know that's
a strong capability that it can bring to
the clinician and point things out so
maybe you know maybe there's you know
maybe there's something that they just
haven't seen before but the computer has
infinite capacity to you know to see
thousands or tens of thousands of cases
of melanoma and make connections you
know that the clinician you know may may
miss so it's you know it's really
problems like that where we look at the
strengths of the computer you know the
ability to look at massive amounts of
data the ability to continuously learn
the ability to be there without any
delay you know the ability to sort of
you know interject it at the right
moment but really ultimately it's
augmentation and scaling that that human
expertise it's not replacing that doctor
for example in the end this is the other
add to that because I just want to pick
up on that so one of the reasons there's
all of this sort of excitement about AI
is that we've made a big dent in solving
perception and the reason that's
profound
is because previous generations of AI
required you to curate the input into a
representation that the machine could
understand and then we'll run with that
right so game playing programs in the
60s and 70s for example you give them a
representation of the problem of the of
the chess board or the backgammon game
or whatever and then within the precepts
of that they did their thing and did
search and all of that sort of cool
stuff and and it
well but you still had to tell the
Machine what it was working on right the
difference now is that machines just
take input directly from the environment
images like vision they can they can see
they can hear they can read and that
makes a big difference because you know
you've just kind of sight step that
laborious process of curating the inputs
for the machine and then having the
machine do kind of the rest of it right
whereas now it's doing the heavy lifting
right from the get-go right from the
source and sort of doing it all the way
now I am a little less optimistic about
the future when I think of the world
that way because one of the basic
Forte's of human beings is our ability
to deal with unstructured data a lot of
the basis of human employment is the
ability to look at images whichever way
they come look at handwriting whichever
the way it comes and then do some simple
sort of logical things on top of that
right and it doesn't matter by the way
whether this is blue collar workers or
white collar workers right machines
don't really care the only thing that
matters is their sufficient amounts of
data available and I think this is what
the excitement is about and the and and
the shifts that are going to happen you
know I was in Toronto Airport the other
day I was on a United Airlines flight
that happened to be a codeshare with Air
Canada so I went to the kiosk tried my
passport no go credit card no go Global
Entry didn't work and so I need a human
so I go into a line that's full of
humans the lines full of humans and I
was thinking this is silly right all you
need is a machine just watching
everything right image recognition
technology is better good enough and it
can just tell Air Canada how many people
they need when to sort of keep things
flowing more freely and sort of sort of
doing things the old way where you know
where a scientist is making assumptions
about poisson arrivals and doing this
heavy-duty modeling and the stuff is
kind of broken at the end of the day as
far as I'm concerned so that's sort of
where a lot of the productivity gains I
feel will accrue is from this ability to
just kind of ingest the raw data and to
be able to make intelligent decisions
with it automatically so that's and
that's gonna have a pretty profound
impact yeah I agree with that like with
the so the data science community we
call it feature engineering so the sort
of standard practices in data science up
to the past couple of years have been to
have a human come in and curate which
aspects of a data set are going to be
most highly correlated with the outputs
that you're looking for so the standard
example I'll give is if you're you've
got a simple model where you're trying
to predict the prices of houses in a
given jurisdiction you go through and
you say well is it going to be the
square footage is it the location is it
some sort of amenity and you might note
that it's the square footage that seems
to be the height the most tightly
correlated what you're looking for so
you focus on that and in these new deep
learning neural oriented systems we that
sometimes there's so many possible
features that could be relevant to
particularly looking for that we sort of
remove that part from the equation and
focus the engineer's activity on
selecting how many layers and a network
might be useful selecting which which
which type of architecture because the
the connections can be oriented in
different ways will be most effective in
in deriving the output that we're
looking for which has led to these
breakthroughs and things like perception
on you know jeopardy is a type of
problem as john mentioned earlier on is
one that's a little bit like entity
extraction or sort of basic equations
right so einstein is the who's the most
famous scientist of the 21st century it
says einstein right so it goes through
wikipedia and can pull that out which is
different from truly interpretative
semantic understanding of text which is
harder to encode in a set of set fast
rules or human selected features and is
leading to some relatively significant
breakthroughs in applications like
automated text summarization where we
can build systems that make our
representation of a very long piece of
text as well as a mathematical
representation of each sentence and then
basically pick out those sentences that
are most closely related to the model of
the whole which is a thing that has
struggled has been a been a struggle for
the research community for a long time
one thing though he mentioned that I
want to disagree with is with the
medical
example and considering these computer
systems more objective than humans
I don't think machine learning systems
are objective and because of the way
that they're trained so in though
there's there's two sort of camps and
machine learning supervised learning and
unsupervised learning
so unsupervised learning is the the
style that we know when we normally
think about machine learning and from a
public perception it's the machine's
magical ability to discern patterns and
data so that exists and it's hard and
it's often used for exploratory analysis
of a data set to get a feel for clusters
of information that have something to do
with one another so that you can then
build a system a lot of the big
breakthroughs in deep learning today
most systems are supervised which means
they require a human to come in and
label a set of data so they give it the
right answer and then the learning is
optimizing the pathways so that when it
sees something that it doesn't know yet
it's been trained the model has been
trained well enough that it can make an
accurate prediction so that means humans
are training them which means there's a
lot of subjectivity baked into the
systems right so a giving an example of
one where this can have ethical
consequences so a good friend of mine
just published a post on medium about a
set of research that was used to detect
an assumed criminality from it just from
someone's photo so these series of
photos this was done in China of of men
and you had sort of the top row when
they're very odd on their white collar
and they looked like nice kind people
and the bottom row are these sort of
smug faces with furrowed brows and you
look at that and you say imagine that
we're in a machine learning system it's
just you as a human who's the good guy
and who's the bad guy and lo and behold
you kind of you know it's like at first
glance you have this intuition so so the
researchers of the papers claimed isn't
this amazing these systems can go out
and automatically identify criminals
just from their faces when in fact you
know basically what the AI has done is
it's revealed to us our prejudices right
our tendencies to look at somebody and
be like yeah that guy's scary and that
guy's not and we do this every day when
we're walking down the streets right so
basically it is if we view a AI there as
as
a magnifying glass to illuminate our own
human biases I think that there's a
powerful ethical discussion to have but
it means that it's the systems we have
to assume that we have to recognize the
systems actually aren't objective
because they they're concatenated our
own human behavior so I think that
indeed is a risk and certainly it's
something we have to take a you know a
lot of care you know in that particular
case you know what was the ground truth
I think that you know that's what it
comes down to you know with a lot of
this training if you're going to be
teaching the computer then is the
information that you are teaching it
with correct and you know in the case of
skin cancer you know well what can you
do you can have a gold standard around
you know the the pathology reports or
you know there can you you can you know
you can work hard to get information
that is correct as possible when you're
training the the the computer I think
these are the things that we have to
strive for I mean I I I fully agree you
know there was always this notion the
machine learning you know prior to this
resurgence which was garbage in garbage
out and I think that still applies today
with deep learning and so on you you
know you have to take a lot of care and
how you train these systems is there in
the next five years is there something
you think is going to be achievable that
you see as you know or potentially
that's striking and I'm thinking
positive here right so I see more and
more sort of decisions getting automated
and and humans will do something else
what they do I don't know right because
there's a lot of talk about well they
won't replace us they'll augment us I'm
just not seeing yet what that will be I
mean I accept the fact that people will
do something different right you're if
they're dangerous jobs that humans have
been doing well better than machines do
them and the human operator does
something else but I don't see exactly
how that's going to sort of liberate us
to do you know more productive things as
has been the case in the past
so I'm sort of agnostic
on this whole view of you know whether
you know like previous waves of
technology AI is no different
you know it'll just make us more
productive but I fear that it'll worsen
inequality you know that it will
actually you know will still require
humans but the kinds of things that we
value about humans like empathy and all
of that I'm not in short supply so
they're not going to be you know sort of
well compensated kinds of jobs so I
worried that you know the the balance is
kind of shifting heavily in terms of
capital you know as opposed to labor
anyway take a shot at the five you think
one of the other reasons why AI is
taking off right now or one of the core
reasons is actually from hardware so
graphical processing units that were
historically used for video games they
do a good job moving electrons and
basically in these parallel matrices as
opposed to just in a straight line like
an a central processing unit that was
great for processing images and leave
until the video games the popularity of
games and it just so happens that the
architecture is also great for the type
of mathematics that's underlying the
types of systems that Fushan was just
describing and it's really that combined
with immense amount of data and just
faster processing powder has really
really led to the the quantum no pun
intended sort of leap in the revolution
recently and there's other types of
hardware advances that are occurring
right now so in this quantum computing
world with the you know and we could
have a session they just did a session
on itself to describe this you can given
given the sort of entanglement
properties that that exist at the atomic
level you can super super impose various
states of a bit so that it's not just
the ones and zeros that we think of in
standard deterministic linear processing
power but from a probabilistic
perspective and machine learning is all
about statistics and probability you can
use one operation to basically like
sample across what could be four states
if you've just got two bits and up to
many many many many many two to the N
levels of states which is which is
significant I think for the types of
operations and the types of hierarchical
and complex pattern
that we look for in machine learning
which could lead to potentially like
even more cool perception or perception
oriented activities the second is most
of the time today
it's very computationally intensive to
train these algorithms so you make the
system smart you bake up the smarts
let's say and a very large cloud
computing architecture so Google and
Facebook etc they're doing most of this
work today centrally but all of the big
companies Google Apple I'd assume
Facebook in some way because of Google
now for unity at Facebook is as well
they're expending a lot of energy right
now to push the training of the
algorithms out onto mobile devices which
means your device will really start to
know you it will it will it will track
your data and it will be personalized to
how you write messages what you like
what pictures you're interested in etc
and the caveat here is we go moments we
think about privacy that could be super
creepy
if these large companies then get access
to all of that data but from what I know
they actually are making attempts to do
this right where they're using some new
privacy techniques called differential
privacy encryption techniques
homomorphic encryption to make sure that
Google never actually gets access to
this fundamental personal data and if we
think about edge computing so all of our
little toasters and showerheads and
everything connected to the Internet
today all that information has to come
back to a centralized server to then
make it back to your fridge to tell you
what to cook next but if that processing
exists out on the edge i I think it
could lead to some like startling new
applications so that's for me that's the
sort of cool super exciting area I just
add one thing there's the area of
augmented reality is very exciting right
so that's kind of the machine learning
coming together with some of the
processing power that Kathryn was
talking about I think that's a world
that you know where Oakman tation will
be really cool and sort of you know the
world seems to be heading that way
because machine learnings become good
enough yeah to facilitate that kind of
stuff hardware's
kind of you know so the algorithms the
AGI that we're talking about good enough
the hardware power is there the speed is
there so we're sort of that's what I
would expect to see a lot of
the augmentation happening the imagine
kids taking a field trip to like the
Great Barrier Reef and swimming around
presuming that we don't kill the earth
ago we're warming and it still exists
soon there's another problem we're not
talking about but like you know and they
could they could snorkel around and have
their little glasses on and have the
taxonomy of the fish be identified in
real time and right so you could like
education could be awesome with with
augmented reality you could take a walk
through the park and have your botany
glasses on you know yes some people are
actually creating sort of doing science
labs where you sort of use you know sort
of augmented reality or virtual reality
where you go in and you can kind of do
sort of experiments in virtual labs and
things like that but just to comment on
sort of this your question I think that
well I already mentioned the brain
machine interfaces and it's already
being used I mean so they have people
sort of like one person sort of like
people who are paralyzed now for example
they're being computer they're being
wired to computers and making now
they're training them to be able to move
different things using their mind to
type you know sort of things on
computers etc etc there are also people
implanting things into their bodies so
that they can use it to open doors you
know pay to check out at counters and
and you can see that sort of I mean
there's this guy with like an antenna
you know
so all that oh that's actually being
done and there's a lot more integration
and again and you know at DARPA is
really at the forefront of a lot of
these technologies and they're trying to
get people to there's something called
the silent op program where they're
trying to get soldiers to be able to
talk to each other using their mind
they're really they're trying to do that
within the next five years that was
within their mandate like within five
years we want a closed-loop system where
the Machine can automatically monitor
what's going on out there and be able to
put that into the user right like an
intelligent autonomous nervous system
back to the outside world and these the
the augmented reality stuff is basically
her as a guide to the outside world that
that's that's exactly right yeah so I
think Catherine described many of these
what I would
called technology enablers I think
quantum is definitely you know has
enormous potential IBM it's a you know
it's a huge direction for for IBM and
its impact will be enormous I mean just
in terms of computation and computation
is important I mean it's actually one of
the primary things that's driving our
ability to learn more complex models and
more sophisticated knowledge and and and
and so on but one of the areas that I'm
very interested in it's an application
of AI is to creativity and if you think
about it you know the sort of the
spectrum of artificial intelligence we
talked a lot about perception the
ability to see and hear and you know and
speak and and and and so on then at the
middle maybe we have more about
knowledge and reasoning but then we're
you know where's creativity I think
creativity is even you know at the
further end of the spectrum and I think
it's even harder to answer the question
you know what is creativity then it may
be to answer what is in intelligence we
can sort of describe a few attributes of
creativity but it's hard to really know
what is you know what is happening and
it's it's really entirely a human
endeavor today so I like to think of you
know myself as an engineer it's about
it's all about method but what creative
people do it to me it still seems to be
magic somehow we did a project at at IBM
in this last year around horror movies
we actually got Watson to watch hundreds
of horror movies so I could think we
sent it to film school I also like to
think I went from you know teaching
Watson to C to teaching Watson to feel
because really what we were able to
encode you know Watson to do around
these horror movies was you know not
only you know not just see objects and
scenes and people and transcribe speech
but characterize the content in terms of
emotion so was a scene that it sounds
scary
did you know did a scene look happy or
did it you know did it look
you know did it look sad you know
something like that and through these
algorithms we were able to get Watson
you know able to make a fairly good
assessment of horror movies but also
horror movie trailers we learned the
patterns for making a horror trailer
essentially it came down to three things
the scenes in a horror movie movie
trailer are either suspenseful scary or
tender that's it but you need you need
all three I mean you know the the
contrast is there and we were able to
take that simple recipe apply it to a
brand-new horror movie and have Watson
do a significant part of making the the
trailer for that movie we just needed a
film editor to come in and within one
day you know create an entire trailer
for the movie so it's a good example of
taking something which is you know might
be a three month effort for a production
team you know down to you know computer
assisted tasks which happened in a day
but I think this just scratches the
surface I think it points to you know a
lot of potential for the computer to be
an assistant to augment the creative
process to do some of the mundane work
the computer is no problem watching
every movie that was ever made if it
comes down to it and can extract
insights and you know can really be an
aid to the creative person certainly in
filmmaking but it goes beyond certainly
goes beyond making movies there's a cool
trend in the computer vision world they
call it style transfer and this was a
neat it's it's an find this in neat
accidental byproduct of the research
process so as people were trying to hone
the algorithms to do the type of work
that John mentioned so comisión
perceptions a computer vision and
perception so being able to accurately
label a picture according to its content
to do that they have to pass it through
this network and it it twists and turns
and transforms the input image and
gradually gets rid of all the noise so
that it can focus on the general
representation that can be affiliated
with a linguistic term cat dog glass of
wine as I've been using during the
during this presentation so as there was
a group of researchers who noticed that
that noise that got removed just so
happened to be what we call artistic
style when they put in paintings so if
you put in Van Gogh's Starry Night and
you pass it through these algorithms it
will pull out the starry night mists and
then you can impose that on your set
your favorite selfie on your Facebook
page right so this I think this actually
there's the the art critical community
has different views on this some of
people say this is kitsch right it's
it's ridiculous that you know our
selfies can become a Rembrandt on the
flip side it actually is a really it
sort of democratizes the skill set
around art so there's an app called
Picasso and I've had some conversations
with the CEO of the app who said while
the critics panned it he had these
influx of emails from people just like
you and I who were like oh my god I
always wanted to paint but I just don't
have time to learn it and now I feel
like I have this like I have this agency
and I can go and I can make a kadinsky
and I can make a you know and I can make
my own Mondrian or whatever and and the
commercial applications are that you
know you can be I've done a lot of work
in startups and we've got no budgets so
we can't afford $50,000 branding
agencies but it's really cool when you
don't have to hire that you can pull out
this app and you can for five cents make
a really professional neat stylistic
website so so it's not you know it's not
quite creativity like we think of it but
there is the sacrosanct miss of of the
you know of genius and art it's it
forces us to ask these big philosophical
questions about what we value in society
when we see that this happens and it
also leads to this whole it from a from
a from a Piston illogical and cognitive
perspective it's teaching us and it's
inspired some research on the
correlations between how we see an align
language with the world that we process
and then how we make art and what's in
what qualifies a style so I think that's
just also super cool you know
consequences of this of this moment you
guys have done stuff with cookie
and other things where do you kind of
come out on this I mean I a the you know
anybody said any kind of real reporting
a research about artificial intelligence
I mean you kind of come away with an
incredible appreciation for what we call
general human intelligence right and
only 20 watts you know low-power you
know just and to get feeds into this you
know the AI debate and particular brain
I mean is is it an inspirational
metaphor or is it a road map computers
do not work like the human brain you
know they are not twenty watts and you
know and they are very fast but they're
not massively parallel it's it's a very
different ability which can have great
impact certainly for data processing and
making you know finding patterns and
making predictions that's really its
strength but in terms of replacing that
twenty watts of human ability that they
bring you know I think we have a ways to
go yeah reminds me the famous line by
one of the pioneers in voice recognition
who worked for IBM Fred jellinek as he
explained it you know airplanes don't
flap their wings they do it yeah that's
right and I think there is something you
know you said is it a metaphor yeah
certainly there's there's a lot to
because you know whatever biological
systems you know human cognition
perception it's it's the best system we
know so we can learn we can certainly
learn a lot by knowing you know knowing
it better you know knowing how it works
it doesn't necessarily mean that's how
we should build our computers so I just
want to come in on the creativity I'm
not sure if it's true that machines can
be more creative than we are I just to
give one example take like alphago right
so when it was playing Lisa DOE and he
made this move is like the 34th move it
was like a move that nobody had ever
made you might think creativity just in
terms of being able to come up with come
with solutions or sort of conceptual
space that hasn't been thought of before
right and to that extent it does satisfy
that criteria of creativity it came up
with ideas that haven't been thought of
before and I think machines are going to
be able to do that they're gonna be able
to locate spaces where we haven't been
to before and so I don't know what you
think about that even when Kasparov
played against you know deep blue and in
in chess it reached the point where he
you know he felt that the computer was
not playing fair right or there was
really a person behind it right because
of whatever move deep blue had made it
just didn't seem logical to him right so
you know I think there is but in the end
what was the deep blue deep blue was a
you know a massive search system there
was no intelligence there right you know
in the way we think you know about a lot
of the problems in AI it just was a
brute-force search problem so sometimes
we might describe some of these
qualities to it but certainly knowing
what was behind the curtain you wouldn't
say you know deep blue was creative
I see ii III think we're talking about
like two types of creativity here I
think what Matthew alluded to was sort
of more in the realm of reinforcement
learning you know I mean Catherine
mentioned supervisor on sulfides because
reinforcement where the reward is
delayed right and so what deep mind has
been really masterful at is just sort of
pushing the limits in terms of
reinforcement learning which in simple
terms boils down to you know you have an
evaluation function you're here you can
evaluate sort of what got you there but
then what's the remaining thing to the
end of the game and that's kind of a
recursive kind of problem and they've
become really good at solving that
problem and so a machine may make a move
and you say wow that's never happened
before that's creative but there's
another aspect of creativity that sort
of is seems to be outside the realm of
these kinds of algorithms which is we
just find ways to do stuff and we can't
quite describe it
such as even dealing with each other
right and
machines are not good at dealing with
people at the moment right that human
machine interface is actually quite poor
they're quite stunted in that sense and
a lot of the research efforts and
creativity I think will make a dent in
that arena in just getting machines to
be more you know empathic or sort of
have the kinds of qualities that we so
seamlessly seem to exhibit the other
unsaid one which is on the flip side so
there's a film called Tim's Vermeer and
I think it's fantastic I think it's
fantastic because it for two reasons one
is it actually forces us to question our
assumptions around human artistic
creativity so this is a movie about some
guy Tim he was a designer at Pixar who
has a theory about the 17th century
Dutch painter Vermeer and wants to test
his theory and he assumes that Vermeer
used an optic system that had two
mirrors one that sort of just reflected
the the the world that he was trying to
depict and then the other one that sort
of shot that reflection down onto a
canvas and then Tim hypothesizes that he
used something like a paint by number
type system to basically use pigment
until there was a color gradient between
what was reflected and what he was
painting and the minute it got there he
short-shifted on and he just sort of
goes through and in a seemingly
extraordinarily uncreated way it made
what were the most realistic and I I'm a
huge Vermeer fan I mean just tantalizing
paintings from the 17th century that
looked radically different from those of
his contemporaries so I think what I
like about that is it also forces us to
its this is less about machine
creativity and more about our
assumptions of what qualifies as as
artistic creativity that has a lot of
ramifications also for the the
scientific research community so you
know I believe that the the myth of the
the solitary genius who sits there and
solves from Oz Last Theorem you know is
not necessarily the way that that
innovation and technology progresses
this is very much back to her and
artificial general intelligence right
there's there's stuff going on
collectively that we from our from our
could trapped in our bodies subjective
viewpoints don't often perceive but if
we could perceive like who knows what
might happen a certain cool thing about
that film is that to make this happen
Tim had to reverse engineer what what he
thought would have been the original
scene so to do it he has to learn about
17th century glass work and textiles and
woodworking and it's kind of this
engineers paradise right because within
this one single project lies of the
world does he have to do all you have to
learn all these things in order to solve
his problems so I like it as a as
something that also forces us to
question our inherited assumptions of
what qualifies as human creativity in
the first place which can be often very
scientific and constraint oriented you
guys you know really worried about what
you you're doing is you know gonna make
the world
a rougher place for more people I think
I think iBM is very clear on this
you know we've outlined the principles
here for a AIA around three dimensions
you know we call it purpose so you know
that a the role is about augmentation of
you know working together with humans
for important industry problems trust
that you know when we build these AI
systems we'll make it very clear how
those models were learned when a AI is
being used what data is behind it you
know and and and so on and then and then
the third is skill it actually comes
back to how these systems are trained
that they're that they will learn from
the human experts you know that it's
it's it is about taking all of that
human expertise and trying to make a
joint computer human capability that's
even better that can you know help scale
expertise you know can help help solve
difficult industry problems so I think
we're very optimistic in you know in the
in the potential if we follow these
three things don't feel compelled if you
don't but if you if you got a point a
strong point of view I'd like to hear
and yeah I I worry I don't have that
optimistic
prognosis unemployment I think the world
be a very cool place there it'll be
amazing machines augmented reality all
kinds of stuff you know my wife
yesterday showed me a Groupon coupon for
data scientists did you expect to see
this so I was like no that's really
interesting and that kind of you know
tells you where sort of people are
focusing on but that's you know everyone
can be a data scientist and if machines
are making lots of these decisions
better than last then we'll be doing
something else I don't know what that is
hard to say what its gonna do for
employment but like I said I worry about
inequality okay I I kind of signed with
the economists here I think there's been
multiple technology revolutions
historically and that jobs haven't
disappeared and if you look through the
history I come from a sort of history
philosophy background people have
worried about the same things time and
time again we talked about it with
there's this film and from 1957 death
set where Katherine Hepburn and Spencer
Spencer Tracy screwball comedy
absolutely fantastic they were all
worried they're gonna lose their jobs in
the 60s and it didn't happen I also do
think though that the fact that
white-collar jobs sub tasks of
white-collar jobs like Investment
Banking lawyering accounting doctors etc
pushes a sensitive button in today's
contemporary society so there's a lot of
people in the world today who have
horrible jobs their jobs they don't
really want and we don't think about
them we're worried about the fancy
things and I think it tells us actually
and some people worried about sort of
you know self-driving cars and what
that's going to do the trucking industry
as well and obviously with the
manufacturing industry but I think that
the fact that you know cognitive tasks
are often hyper specialized
which is a great candidate for narrow
narrow intelligence leads to some
discomforts with the way in which our
society is currently constructed that
people are reacting to so I think that
there is going to be some sort of it's
going to transform our society there's
going to be transition costs so people
are gonna lose their jobs and it's not
so easy to retrain people you know
especially if you're in your 50s etc etc
to try to retrain to say oh you can take
a course on data you know my name is
you know it's it's very hard right and
so that's gonna it's gonna hurt a lot of
people and so I do think that we need a
discussion in our society about the
inequalities that are going to result
that raise it you know so in the long
run maybe so just like you know you know
when we transition from horse buggies
the cars right people lost jobs etcetera
etcetera we need to be able to do but
this is this time it's gonna happen even
faster right and so we as a society need
the people to deal with that transition
and to like what how do we help these
people do we do something like universal
basic income etc etcetera but we do need
to have that conversation otherwise it's
gonna there the inequality is gonna be
hugely as a Serb aidid and that's gonna
be really bad and the technologists
should be part of that debate so we have
time for some questions if there are
they're people with microphones my main
concern is how we should educate the
generation there's gonna be like my son
here who is 12 which type of profession
how we should encourage them knowing
that it's gonna be harder I've written a
lot about this topic in education in
this age so I think you know as we've
been talking about this whole debate
between artificial general and narrow
intelligence the this you know general
as a model or something that it really
is not achieved yet and there's a lot of
value and are being able to do multiple
things right so not just focusing on one
single thing but really the value of a
classical liberal art liberal liberal
arts education right so really sort of
learning not only one thing but but many
things will be valuable in the future
and then the other thing as Matthew just
mentioned skills transfer so the most
valuable skill set that one can have
today is the ability to loon learn new
things because as the technology keeps
changing you don't want to get stuck in
a thing where you know you kind of have
this one skill and if you can't perform
that skill then you're out of a job if
you can go on a MOOC right so a massive
online open course and learn a new skill
when you're 25 when you're 30 when
you're 35 that's going to be sort of the
these are going to be the Darwinian
fits for the new economy and I don't
know there's no the education system
hasn't solved this at all
you know there's and I hope that the
technologists will be in dialogue with
the education policymakers to make sure
that both general general education as
well as skills transfer will be will be
focused on in the future the thing that
you're really looming on the horizon
that I see is the self-driving car I
think there's a lot of money going there
and they really want to make it happen
very quickly one of the things that keep
hearing is gonna happen within 5 years
so you know obviously how does this I
feel like it's gonna be shoved down our
throats rather than we're gonna be
allowed to arrive at some sort of
organic solution so what do you guys see
is how is this gonna be implemented so
maybe I can come so one of the things
that we haven't really talked about is
sort of how do we build ethics into AI
and that's sort of very prominent in the
case of self-driving cars so as a
philosopher we talk about the trolley
problems so what happens when a trolley
goes towards my people you know what
that's just doing with this health
freight car imagine now the cars driving
it's and it could kill five people or
who could kill you right could sort of
turn off to the side of the road killing
you right what should the car do and how
should what how should the program or
program that into the car and would you
buy a car that will kill you right even
though maybe that's the right thing to
do right and so and who gets to decide
that so there's a sort of there's who's
gonna like build in these sort of ethics
into the AI so that's sort of a huge
area that hasn't really been discover
that people are starting to discuss now
my take on that has to do with sort of
like different geographical locations
are a better fit for self-driving cars
so Singapore would be great right so
self-driving cars work the best if it's
if we go from human to all cars all soft
drivers all human today also driving
tomorrow because once you've got all the
cars that are talking one another with
their sensors it becomes a very static
system it loses a lot of complexity
Bangalore is the worst place for
self-driving cars because if you ever
been to Bangalore it's like people are
honking and driving all over the places
of traffic lights right so it would be
super hard it goes back to the as Vashon
was saying with the like quickness with
which you have to make a decision
level of chaos in your system so I do
think like this is going to be the
technologies there you know and it's
going to be a policy decision where
certain who knows in the states if it'll
be over that starts because there is
aggressive as they are and they're just
gonna put the fleet out and god knows
what will happen and you know and then
they'll get sued and they'll pay it off
and the next thing you know everybody
will have self-driving cars right but um
you know I think that it'll be a
geographically specific area there'll be
somewhere that's more of a Singaporean
like state that will probably be like
the early adopter and then it'll
gradually shift - I can't imagine when
it'll make it this place like India just
because of the but I think that so that
so this sort of that but the interesting
point is gonna be this this middle
threshold where you know you've got some
human drivers and some self-driving cars
and you've got these I can't remember
what they call it but it's sort of
there's like four levels of self-driving
cars from you know cruise control to
full automation and right now there's a
lot of work on the like when does the
human intervene who's liable when the
human intervenes you know and it goes
into the ethics and IP right so it's
like is it the car maker how do we do we
model this like a software liability
problems so I think right now the issue
is really one of policy and ethics but
there was another point earlier on that
is also relevant for self-driving cars
we hold computers often to higher
standards than human behavior and in the
self-driving car world there's so many
accidents per day that it's kind of a
no-brainer that we should go to the
autonomous vehicle paradigm even if
there will be accidents there will be
fewer than there are with human drivers
but it's so hard to get people to
appreciate that right so for me this is
the sort of like the messy debate in the
in the space right now and it's no no
mess well I think we're we're a little
past time here well thank the panelists
and all you for coming
you
[Music]